هناك حالات مثل هذه الوفيات في جميع الحروب
في البداية ننتصر ونحن أقوياء ونحن كذلك
الهواتف المحمولة وكل شيء على ما يرام، الكثير من الأشياء من الأيام الستة
لكن 90 يوما من ذلك، في كل حرب هناك مرحلة مطلوبة
تعرف على المكان الذي قد تبدأ فيه بفقدان قوتك
تبدأ بالخسارة لأن الجيش هو العدو
التعرف على أن لديك قصة
وللشرعية قصة نذير شؤم وكوارث
ويمكن القول أن هذا حدث في كل الحروب حتى الآن
لدينا عادة استراتيجية لا تمتلكها الحكومة الإسرائيلية
العمل والتحييد بشكل أساسي سياسياً بسبب الشركاء
ائتلافات نتنياهو وبالتالي في معظم الفترة
إنه أمر صعب بالنسبة لنا من الناحية الاستراتيجية
نحن بحاجة إلى مباراة ممتازة مع الأمريكيين ومباراة
ممتاز مع المصريين عن محور فيلادلفيا وماذا
ستكون مسألة من سيسيطر على المليونين
في الواقع، لاجئون، نتنياهو يرسل رسائل نصية باستمرار إلى ديون
أن الغرض الاستراتيجي يمكن أن تكون النتيجة
لكي تكون كل الجهود الهائلة التي بذلناها يمكن أن تتعثر
ويقودنا إلى صفر إنجازات لوحل غزة وخلاص
المزيد منا في الكثير ممن يريدون دولة إسرائيل
لن تنتصر في الحرب في غزة، أولاً يمكنك تسميتها
عمال الطرق بجميع أنواعهم الذين يفضلون العزل
نتنياهو يوافق على قرار حماس بالإضافة إلى عوفادي
الطريق هناك أولئك الذين يعملون للأميركيين
ومنشغلون بالحلول السياسية بدلاً من المقام الأول
في قرار عسكري وأمني، يليه خلاف، هناك
بالمناسبة، وكلاء الإحباط على اليمين وعلى اليسار
الذين يحاولون تحقيق بعض الربح السياسي الصغير وليس
فهم حجم الساعة تتم مناقشته أن الميزة
وفي القتال في غزة لا يوجد تهديد حقيقي لطائرات الجيش
والهواء هنا شيء أ. طائرات الجيش
الهواء يحلق عالياً ويهاجم من الأعلى هنا
على متن طائرة هليكوبتر، تحلق المروحية بشكل أساسي على ارتفاع منخفض وهي تفعل ذلك
أكثر عرضة للخطر ولكننا نرى أن الصاروخ ليس كذلك
ضربته هناك أنظمة في الطائرة وفي المروحيات التي تعرف
تضليل الصواريخ والقذائف عادة لا تفعل ذلك
إيذاءهم لا شيء ليس محكمًا بل هو حدث
ماذا حدث بالأمس عندما أطلق إرهابيو حماس صاروخا
اكتب S7 باتجاه مروحية البومة التابعة للقوات الجوية
وفي ساحة انتظار السيارات أخطأ الصاروخ المروحية
أطلقت أعيرة نارية كجزء من تلك العملية لمغادرة المنطقة
المكان وفي النهاية أصاب الصاروخ المعالج
كيبوتس نيريم للشفاء تضرر في معركة هيا
لنكتشف ذلك في جنين، قل كم مرة
لسنوات كنت تنعم بالراحة في مخيم للاجئين مع جانين بالفعل
كم سنة جيدة نجحت فيها وليس بقدر ما قطعت
صدى ذلك بلغة الجيش، وليس باللغة التي سترونها
لذا فإن السؤال هو ما هو النجاح، وكأن السؤال هو هل
لم يكن هناك السابع من أكتوبر أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل
ولهذا قد يكون نتاج مرحلة، لكنه قيد الإعداد
هل تعلم أنه في العملية الأخيرة في جنين وجدت
الأنفاق من المسجد إلى جميع أنواع الأماكن بأسرع ما يمكن
لا تتصرف في الواقع بقوة أكثر عدوانية من
الذي كنت تفعله حتى الآن أنت تقوم بنوع من التاكو
مثل هذا والانتظار
إلى ذلك